and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review real Steve
how many God is the greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
spike yours there's this guy who's
Wolverine and he lives in a future with
anybody fights with Rock'em Sock'em mm
Oh will transformers hmm
trains morphix hey and Wolverine has his
robot in the South fighting a ball I
fought a bull once he won but it turns
out Wolverines robots aren't very good
and he owes money all over town so he
goes to Kate from lost I have only one
question it's not about the ending to
lost is it no can I have some money no
in that case what was up with the ending
today oh but then it turns out Wolverine
has a little boy whose mother just died
and Wolverine is like I want nothing to
do with you little boy who's being
adopted by an incredibly rich and
wealthy person who wants you very badly
I let you have him for a significant
absolutely not judging that's better
don't worry the doctor than a boy whose
vocabulary is a legend and credible I'm
serious this kid is way too smart for an
11-year old he says words like words
that I can't so I go into a drug Darren
stealing parts for their robots and they
come across this adorable Robo with a
stitched up smile I'm off to see the
Wizard to get some brain you mean a
heart right everyone else needs the
brain so the kid goes up to the
broken-down robot him is like are you
like no but the boobies gonna act like I
am bro because nobody likes moving for a
toaster in the climax so they call the
Machine Adam and put him in all these
fights and the kid becomes Hannah's
manager
Lauren is like way anti grounded and the
other managers are like why don't you
listening to this kid so Adam starts
winning all these fights but it turns
out they wanted to go up against the
ultimate champion Zeus but unfortunately
Zeus is run by Treecko and that russian
chick oh sorry wrong Lupe's Zeus is run
by an Asian guy and that russian chick
as you can see anything Zeus touches he
destroyed by wrong movie that's at
that's right as you can see anything
suzy's he killed mm-hmm yes that was
totally different but I can't grab the
microphone after the fight because he's
freaking nuts and he challenges Zeus to
a fight another seriously fuck you
doesn't mean we have a fight yes
no shit hey but it turned all over and
is giving the kid back to his legal
guardians and Waring is like it's better
for you this way I'm a bad fighter just
because you're a bad father doesn't mean
you're a bad father watch fighter poo
but that over een is like you know
having a big cliched cheesy canaanites
isn't the same if there is a little boy
crying in the audience listen I'm not
just vocabulary to them not just okay oh
sure so everybody in the final battle
thing - Adam is gonna get his ass kicked
but what a surprise he kiss his ass
kicked my boy cried was trying to clean
up and just when it looks like he's down
for the count
Adam gets the energy to get back up
through a backup battery some sort of
internal hard drive that will boot up in
case anything went wrong well power
Johnny number 5 is alive yes we're sort
of vaguely saying that so the asian guy
is like I must break you
oh no I mean girl goes the distance and
makes it through all the rounds and even
man just maxes out
but in the end adding up all the points
it looks like Zeus wins in the
audience's like boo go back to Russia
Asia but the Russian lady who is
obviously terrible at PR says we want we
want you stupid suck it
but the announcers like little boy with
the matches vocabulary what it like to
be the people's champion
I have no spray so as you can tell Real
Steel is up Real Steel if you like
transformers which I never saw but
you're absolutely gonna love Real Steel
I know I'm hi Andrew this is history
bumsang giant you got change ha ha ha
every guy oh me yeah come on Shay
looking at least buy me a copy of
transformers here is the best Republic
of you Panda